the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
thank you
hello everybody and welcome to week one
of the pro chess League I am here in St
Louis where we are going to be having a
very exciting imaginary match that has
actually just started already and we're
going to be jumping into it we're going
to be giving you all the details but
first I do want to introduce you to our
captain Captain Nemo will be here with
us helping us discuss the games today
that have just started Nemo it's great
to be with you
Jonathan I really appreciate you
guys having me as the captain for the St
Louis archbishops I hope these will be
really exciting the games have already
started and as a reminder to everybody
we are on a one minute delay so if we
don't respond or if we don't see your
message immediately it is because of
that we have access to all of the pro
video cameras and the games ahead of you
that is right and with that let's
actually jump straight to the action we
have a lot to discuss we have a lot to
go over but a game has already started
and if there's one thing I know about
YouTube it's that you just got to start
the video in the action so right now we
have linear Dominguez going up against
Lou yaping from the Shanghai tigers and
you can tell that there are some moves
on the board the music is excessively
loud in my opinion but here we go let's
just jump into it uh and we'll see where
things go from here uh Nemo it's great
to have you I don't know if you've seen
any of this game so far but one of our
top boards is linear Dominguez he's got
the black pieces so I imagine there's a
way I could flip it to see it from the
archbishop's point of view and here we
go we have a Queen's Gambit accepted on
the board already with Knight to F3 uh
Knight F6 E3 here's our position
probably some very standard stuff so far
an interesting choice I suppose by black
the much higher rated opponent if
they're looking to play for a win I
normally really think if this is
something you do to maybe equalize but
you know what here we are this is our
position in a way we go so uh anyways
it's good to have you on the stream it's
a real pleasure to be here could you I
guess let's just start off off the top
so you are the team captain for our show
could you let me know what what exactly
that means because this year I think
it's a little bit different every team
has their own Captain but I'm not
exactly sure what it means what are you
what does it all mean
um I believe that as the captain it
means I am doing content and I know that
we are still you know sorting out a
couple of technical difficulties it is
our first time so you guys don't see the
clocks yet I'll give you guys a rundown
it's currently nine minutes to uh seven
and fifty and we're on move 13 so that
will be all added really quickly and as
Jonathan mentions between Dominguez and
lo e ping
um so yeah I will be doing a lot of the
content this is our first broadcast so
it's a little bit scuffed so far but we
we will get this all going really really
soon
um and I'm really excited to just be
bringing a couple of you know exclusive
interviews hopefully the St Louis team
won't be making it to the final four so
you'll see me there in person amongst
other things I do not have the right to
decide who plays and who doesn't play uh
so do keep that in mind if anything does
happen because is you know I'm not
responsible for the players
our manager of the team is the one and
only Mike cummer who's been doing an
excellent job he's helped lead us to
list the victories in the Pro chess
League I believe we have three titles
under our belt as well as if you count
the U.S uh chess League which was the
predecessor of this it is four in total
so
yeah
um all right well in this case I
understand you guys don't see the
players just yet but black is playing uh
black is Dominguez who is on the same
Bishop uh St Louis archbishop's team so
you know for now we're just following
black I'll keep relaying you guys to
time and everything
we don't care that much about who white
is no I'm completely joking but uh no
white white is a very very strong 2500 I
am I don't actually even know if he's
2500 he's probably higher rated than
that you know coming from China it's
quite difficult to get a lot of feeder
rated tournaments in
um especially you know with the current
situation where they're still not fully
able to travel and all that so we'll
we'll see I'm sure the the opponent is
you know equally
is is really strong obviously Dominguez
has been a notable Grandmaster for a
really long time perhaps Jonathan you
can actually shine a little bit more
light on how Dominguez came to join the
team how you know you guys decided on
such an amazing roster of players so
yeah every single roster decision we
have uh we have a method to the madness
Mike Comer has his own very special ways
there's some very particular rules with
the pro chess league for who can play
and what ratings count for what uh I
know we might even have a Graphic for it
but we can show every team will be
having at least one female on their team
and the ratings it works kind of
interesting because you can't just put
all 2700s on your team the way it works
is you need to include at least two
women uh on your entire roster and you
need to include at least one Junior born
in 2003 or later teams can then add up
to eight players by mid-season and
players need to stick around with the
team as they play one game so uh that is
kind of what goes into it and then even
on a weekly basis the way that it works
is you can't just stack your team with
the top four players in the world
there's a little bit uh to it we could
flip to potentially the lineup rules so
every single week you will see it every
team will include at least one woman for
a total cap of 25.50 average rating and
anybody that's over 2 700 counts as a
2700 So Magnus Carlson he's a 2700 as
far as the lineup's concerned but on the
same Pace anybody under 2200 counts as a
2200 so if you put a 100 rated player in
your your lineup just to lower your
rating it actually will count as a 2200
and any women that's 23.50 or above uh
will actually count as a 23.50 to
encourage more women to be able to play
and that's we're using the few day
standard ratings as of November 1st so
my camera has a tough job to do because
the total cap is 25.50 so you can't just
sit there and just stack you know to the
roof with the top four players there it
does take like a particular you're
looking for lower rated players that are
potentially underrated you're looking
for the highest rated players that you
possibly can and Mike usually does a
very good job coming up with our
matchups on the day today and I don't
think we have a full list of the St
Louis Archbishop roster but I can tell
you for a fact that it is Fabiano
caruana is on the team not playing today
lenier Dominguez is here with us today
Jeffrey Zhang is in the roster but he's
not playing today you will see Benjamin
Bach play today Nicholas theodoro will
be playing today then we have varusian
akobian Rochelle Wu Alice Lee is
somebody that we will be checking out
later in this broadcast then we have
Julian perlaco and Sophie Morris Suzuki
that is the entire lineup for the uh for
the team and I believe we actually do
have clocks now and we can get back
there hasn't been too much action in the
game so far and it's I don't know it
feels like to me it's a bit of a strange
way or maybe this is just linear's
approach she's obviously the much higher
rated player and he's gone for like a
completely symmetrical Pawn structure
where it feels like I don't know
everything is going to be equal for like
around a long time and maybe he's just
open to get his opponent into some end
game in the future because it looks like
we're swapping off a lot of Rooks Bond
structure is exactly the same could be a
lot of trades on the horizon what do you
think of this position so far
all right I think maybe we have lost
Nemo temporarily so we will work to get
her getting ready hello there we go okay
I was just saying
um the position is very very equal and
I'm a little bit concerned about
dominguez's usage of time in a position
that is so equal because this is a rapid
game he has four minutes 53 on the clock
his opponent has 6 minute 40. so you
know there's there's a little bit of
extra time for the opponent right now
and
spending spending so much time on a
singular move like Rick da does does not
make too much sense to me I'm not quite
sure what Dominguez is thinking about
here it is a very very equal position
yeah just a move ago he did it was right
here that he spent uh quite a bit of
time and he just comes up with yeah I
mean I guess a relatively
straightforward simple trading the
pieces kind of move and then we see H3
so it would be interesting to see if the
opponent actually plays quickly and is
able to somehow put Dominguez under time
pressure but uh they still have quite a
bit of time we'll see how it goes from
here but I'm as far as I'm concerned
we're going to be seeing quite a lot of
Trades and I'm not sure that that's the
right match strategy the goal is to get
eight and a half total points uh it is a
four versus four so all of our our board
one will play against their boards one
two three and four boards two Everybody
Plays everybody one time and whoever
gets the most points wins and I think
one also interesting thing is that
there's no uh tie breaks this year or
there's no ties you're not allowed to
draw the actual match this year which I
think is something that's a little bit
difference so there will be something
decisive and we're counting on your
highest board you expect your highest
board to be able to put together a lot
of wins for you so we'll see what
happens here but anyways the match for a
match format is a 4x4 between the two
chess teams all plays all the time
controls are ten plus two the first team
to eight and a half points will win the
match and the tie break is we will
replay round four pairings if we have to
that's when all of the top seeds are
playing each other board one plays board
one the second highest rate of players
play the second highest rate of players
until we finally do get a winner that's
how it is going to be working and I know
that it is a particularly complicated
elimination Swiss season uh the way that
the entire season is going to be running
is also particularly complicated but you
want to win every match because if you
uh can after week one the teams will
face everybody with the same record it's
a Swiss bracket pairings there's 16
total teams competing for eight playoff
spots after week one the team faces
those with the same records three winds
secures the playoff spots three losses
eliminates you from playoff contention
and then in the middle there's a lot of
room for possibility but everybody is
trying to get those three wins just to
make sure that they secure uh their
spots because after week two you will
see teams starting to drop outs okay we
also might see Rooks eventually get
traded on the D file we're eager very
eventually though both players yeah for
sure
um I mean this game is I'm still like
you know I care a lot about time when it
comes to chess I'm not sure what your
favorite time control is Jonathan but I
love my bullet chess and I'm getting
quite concerned for Dominguez so as far
as I know about dominguez's Chess play
he he has traditionally got it in time
trouble even in his classical chess I'm
a little concerned here because the time
difference is growing so
um not really sure where the thought is
going I'm a little concerned
yeah he's down what do you think two
minutes I mean it is like I expect him
yeah he's notably a very very solid
player he doesn't take like a huge
amount of chances but it's interesting
to see him playing against somebody
that's much lower rated like if you're
constantly playing against Fabi and
Magnus like I get it that's a very solid
approach that's taken you very far
you've done very well with it but now
you're playing on a team match where you
need to win the team is really counting
on you but maybe his his idea is he's
just gonna draw with black or maybe he's
like I can still win you know I'm linear
Dominguez look the closer we get to the
end games the better it'll be for me but
even if he is a bullet player maybe he
is a bullet player maybe we're going to
see him he's like just wait till I get
one minute on my clock then I'll pick up
the pace
I do want to add that all of the other
games have started as well we're doing
stacker starts so we can drop in on uh
you know we can drop on Benjamin's game
let's go in order
Benjamin Bach is playing against Shu e
all right and I did want to add that all
of the Chinese players have ratings of
about 2500 except for Wei who's 2700. as
a reminder Chinese players can be very
underrated because they don't get enough
tournaments within the country itself
and it's very hard to travel currently
so even though the St Louis archbishops
might have an rating Advantage right now
don't forget everybody also plays
against each other so
you know wow all right so anything can
happen we're gonna need to be very
careful in this one hopefully Mike
stacked the team accordingly but here's
the game it's some gioko piano some very
quiet Italian game hopefully we get
something really exciting to get us
going here uh but so far relatively
typical stuff oh we see A6 followed by
A5 this is all relatively standard and
normal for such openings these ones they
always have like so many tiny nuances
every single line in the Italian here we
see the Knight take the bishop right
away which is interesting just leaving
the bishop hanging uh and after that
Bishop is taken the Knight is now going
to need to retreat so it goes all the
way back we see this capture we'll we'll
see he doesn't want to take back with
this Pawn I suppose takes back with the
queen
uh White is kind of looking for anything
basic weaknesses but maybe this is all
right we see a lot of night maneuvering
Queen comes in she's begging for a trade
that I don't think black is willing to
go for
and here is the position that they got
to after the night goes back to A7 and
we see the Rook take a pawn so we've
seen a sacrifice now
black takes the pawn back here we are
let's just get to our current position
okay so this is a little bit different
it's a little bit more strategically
complex than the position that we were
looking at just a moment ago but again
it's kind of a symmetrical Pawn
structure this is becoming a theme
uh of this it is it is I mean when you
get a lot of strong players playing
against each other right
um there's this really famous saying on
my channel where people like to say the
BET like perfectly play games or Draw
yeah and I do have to agree when you
have some really high rated players some
people who really know how to play chess
they're not blundering their pieces all
the time
surprisingly you might end up in a lot
of positions where the position is
actually equal so I'm not too worried
about all these equal positions I I'm
confident in Benjamin's ability to
squeeze out an edge even though the pawn
structure is completely equal I don't
quite see where the advantage is
currently but at the same time an end
game just because it's an equal end game
does not mean it's necessarily A draw
here Benjamin might be going for a
knight to C4 and obviously white is
playing Knight to D2 to stop Knight to
C4 also reinforcing the E4 Pawn a little
bit so we still have all of these really
Dynamic ideas in these kind of positions
wow Rook to B8 was just played
Rook to B8 now there is a mysterious
move
what's Rook to B8 all about
I
I not tell you
I I really don't know
um yeah sometimes here we go sometimes
it just happens so the idea is emerging
so okay he prayed work to be eight and
now Rook to A5 and so I suppose the idea
is if you were now to capture The Rook
on A5 you'd be able to take back with
the B Pawn in The Rook on B8 would be
staring down the opponent's bee Pawn wow
okay so a very interesting idea so white
does not want to trade but rather plays
B4 and is asking black are you going to
trade or are you going to run your Rook
all the way back avoiding the trade okay
so we have our eyes on this one the
Dominguez game has ended in a draw
unsurprisingly
right but that does make sense
but yeah just let me know if you'd like
me to keep going around the board I've
actually never I mean in charge of the
boards for these shows it's a it's a
first time okay
right I still can't see your shared
screen so I'm just trying to follow
along based on what you say Okay
um but that's totally fine I was
thinking we can drop into the June June
versus Nicholas wonderful okay let's
check this out yes let's go ahead and
just um
so this is Nicholas theodoro with the
white pieces Julian June with the black
pieces
uh we have some sort of Catalan going on
here
where okay we're getting this B5 line
where black will at least for the
moments hold on to this Pawn we'll see
if she gets to keep it forever E4 is
played E5 Knight D5 Knight E4
and all right it's Queen to H5 look here
we got like some exciting action it
looks like white is sacking upon and
potentially trying to play for some sort
of attack Knight F3 B takes uh A4 is an
interesting idea but now Knight F to G5
look white is putting all of these
pieces next to the king this could be
fun
after age six Knight goes back to age
three Queen E8 Queen E2 F5 e takes F5
Knight takes F6 Queen takes C4 A5 okay
so much potential here the knights are
hopping in Queen has covered the age
five yeah okay okay and then maybe we're
simmering down and trading a little bit
in the ends but this is our current
position after Bishop to E3 where it
looked like for a moment white was doing
some interesting things on the king side
but maybe now with this openf file June
Wayne June might be able to put a little
bit of pressure on white what do you
feel about this position
really like Joan Jin's position in this
in this case I mean obviously
um she has a slightly weak Pawn
structure so I'm assuming that
Nicholas's main idea should be to go
into an end game but at the same time
you know she's time is running a little
bit low so we have to see if she's
really able to use what time she has
left in order to create an attack on
White's
um
King structure so as long as as Nicolas
gets out of this I I think he'll be
totally okay
yeah so we'll see what happens here I
know you always have your eyes on the
clock June way June now is under two
minutes Nicholas theodoro has about
three minutes on his clock so there's a
lot to uh discuss here we can really
quick take a look at uh the highest
rated opponent going up against our
lowest rated player as well this is the
game between Alice Lee with white going
up against uh way Yi with the black
pieces there's a very large difference
in the rating so we'll see how they
handle it here it's some sort of like
modern defense this is actually kind of
an interesting system for black they're
playing with this early Knight to C6
they're not playing D6 or anything kind
of encouraging white to eventually come
forward but Ellis is saying no she's not
going to move her pawns forward until
black plays E5 uh we're gonna get some
interesting position the Knight is
coming into D4 we're seeing uh her
Bishop pop back because maybe she wants
to play F3 at some moments which is
exactly what happens C5 occurs on the
board B4 playing on the queen side
King's maneuvering this is going to be
fast fascinating this is definitely an
interesting approach very provocative by
way Yi this game but wait are these
clocks real way Yi is under a minute
Alice Lee has almost four minutes on her
clock this doesn't make any sense they
can't have spent that much time I'm not
sure if I should trust the clocks or not
I don't trust the clocks I mean they
played 17 with
no way that weighs I
I know yeah they know but I I'm a little
bit sus at this time we'll know in 20
seconds if he doesn't make a move if
they keep playing or not if these times
are real but yeah we'll stick here for
just a second
right well we'll we'll keep an eye out
on this I mean at the current moment I
really like Alice uh Lee's position and
I noticed someone commented in the chat
that Dominguez Drew their lowest rated
the board four yeah and I do want to add
that once again you just never know what
might happen in chess right it's the
lowest rated player can definitely draw
the highest rated player especially
because a lot of his player is also 2500
I mean right that's a pretty strong
board four so you know the Shanghai
tigers are not messing around they're
Fielding their
strongest players against the St Louis
archbishops and
it's just uh it's going to be a tough
match it's going to be a tough match for
sure
all right and we might actually be able
to bring in a camshot of Alice Lee who
has a very tough first matchup right now
and it is I mean again you mentioned
that this is kind of a good position for
white I feel like this is one of those
positions where you always like oh this
is so good for me as white but then
somehow the opponent is so much higher
rated and you're like wait a minute at
some point it gets difficult to find the
way forward this feels like it's good
for white but your opponent is Wei ye
and then things get complicated
okay
so we're going to see what happens
absolutely brought Alice up on the
screen you can see her playing chess
there
her position but I don't know if the
board is updating as it should be okay
clock has run to zero
uh so you know we will
be updated momentarily
I do believe the Jew Engine versus
Nicholas game is still going on so we
can drop in and take a look at that so
we stopped around here there's new moves
Knight to D3 letting a queen trade
happen Pawn is coming to E4 wait he's
grabbing all the puns
wait white just grabbed all the puns
wait this is fantastic
this is looking amazing right I mean
this is what happens
if Joe and Jin's attack doesn't succeed
then white has this slightly better end
game because would you enjoy the pawn
structure is just so weak she has those
double pawns on the a file she had the
isolated C Pawn which is on a half open
file she's got that you know e-pawn that
has nowhere to go I'm not really sure
what this E4 move was yeah E4 was very
strange it was clearly so she gives up a
pun and I'm not sure what she may have
missed in a position like this
I don't know hopefully maybe she was
hoping for simplifications maybe didn't
maybe he thought the bishop was going to
take on F5 here or something and just
trade the Bishops I'm not exactly sure
but instead we see Bishop takes C6
counter-attacking the Rooks so leaving
the Knight hanging and then after the
Rook moves anywhere you're able to play
E4 and now white just has this these
massive Pawns in the center and should
have a fantastic game just there they go
the bonds are moving the pawns are
pushing presumably he's just going to
take back the bishop on F4 in our
current position
and these ponds should be enough to win
the game so let's stick here and we can
see if Nicholas theodoro will be able to
pull this one off and and get the uh the
first win our other two games that have
finished so far linear Dominguez game
and the Benjamin Bach game both ended in
a draw so we're looking for somebody to
get some points on the board and maybe
it's all up to Nicholas
absolutely
um
can we drop in again on the Alice game
is that still not updating so I don't
have any new moves in this game after
visit to F2 we're a little bit stuck
here
so I guess we can I'll keep our eyes on
the theodoro game because we still for
sure got moves coming in
right and then uh we'll we'll bounce
back as soon as we can see something
happen in that game it's the clocks are
a bit funky here I'm not I'm not sure if
anybody's in time trouble but if you
look at the clocks everybody's under 20
seconds and here they're moving fast so
maybe I do believe it
are they just gonna make a draw no oh no
don't make a draw
oh well I mean to be fair it's a very
it's a slightly
Huff position I think to you know feel
confident pushing for a win when the
engine line Rook to E4 uh King D2 King
to D two sorry Rook to D4
King to C1 and your king is on the
Square we can make the moves over the
board as well um just to give the
viewers a clear idea of what's going on
um not everybody has that's good
visualization as you and I Jonathan
but this could be a little yeah scary
for white to play
if I yeah if I just keep checking I
guess the question is how do I actually
Escape these checks the computer finds
some way
or is there does the computer actually
find a way wait the computer just keeps
saying go back wait what happens on uh
Rook to C4 and King to B1 yeah so this
is the way that you would try
yeah so if you just give checks like
this I don't know if you can see my
screen but if you just check on C2 with
the bishop the king is going to run all
the way to A3 and you're going to be
totally safe so what would black
actually play after King to B1
well I think this is the winning line
for what yeah it looks like maybe this
was the way now I will easily exit
analysis
but this game did end in a draw oh no
yeah well you know Nicholas had
not not Nicholas didn't have a lot of
time on his clock I honestly can't
really blame him it just looked really
scary he probably thought that after the
whole line and after Bishop to C2
um you know after sorry after King C1
Rook C4 King B1 Bishop C2 King to A2 and
Bishop to B3 for example yeah you don't
know if you're getting made it or not
right you're very stuck
yeah he might have seen some ghosts with
Rook to G3 he might have just you know
not really calculated this line assumed
that black must have had Perpetual so
you just don't really know about those
kind of situations but at the same time
when you only have four seconds left on
the clock as somebody who has played a
lot on their time control uh time
trouble you definitely don't want to
risk losing right when you for sure have
a draw especially against you and Jin
who World Championships and stuff like
that recently it's still a really good
draw but on paper a a good result here
for Nicholas theodoro but you know it it
feels like maybe we missed a chance
hopefully we're not coming back to this
at the end thinking to ourselves oh no
if if it was theodoro could have just
won this game maybe there'd be a chance
but it's only round one and the other
thing is we have the the Alice Lee
way e-game but there's just not been any
moves here so this year we appear to be
stuck so we know we got at least three
draws and we're not exactly sure that
the result has not been marked for this
game we can see Alice on the screen it
looks like she
oh maybe we can see her board in the
Deep background
it looks like the the final position
maybe their game has ended
trying to gather from her face if does
she look happy or sad it's not easy to
tell
oh but they're making moves yeah okay
she has a computer screen behind her and
she's making moves
we're just having transmission errors I
believe
um Alice lost according to my channel
and the tigers are now leading two and a
half to one and a half oh no all right
so the yeah the Tigers strike first yeah
the Tigers have striked first
um but you know
there's always all of the other games
we're gonna play I'm trying to do the
math for how many games are going to
keep happening and I I can't even do the
math for it I like literally can't
they're playing everybody you're playing
everybody at least once
so there's a lot of games still going on
there will be still a lot of games going
on
all right I have Rick's clicking refresh
it has done absolutely nothing I risked
it live
um but yeah so there will be 16 total
games there's four per round so eight
and a half is what you need to win the
match so okay obviously draws are a half
point we can see that they at some point
where you will have one point so this
brings their total don't worry I'm great
at math they have two and a half points
we have one and a half
my producer didn't correct me so I know
that I'm right and now there'll be some
sort of small break and then we'll we'll
get this going and you know what we had
a this is just to make it a little bit
more exciting for the fans now we have
something to look forward to and we'll
see uh if the team is able to pull it
off
uh just a reminder to everybody of the
format if you've just joined us this is
a four by four between the two chess
teams everybody will be playing
everybody the time control is 10 minutes
with a two second delay and that has
played a very important role in every
single game we've seen so far the first
team to eight and a half points will win
the match and there will be a tie break
if necessary and we will be playing the
round four pairings the round in which
all of the top seeds uh play each other
until one team wins now it's uh let's go
ahead and get a sneak peek at to the
pairings of round two before we jump
into all of the action we are going to
see Lanier Dominguez our top seed going
up against yeju of the Tigers we are
also going to be seeing Benjamin Bach
going up against yipping Liu so far we
have a an advantage on both of our top
boards we're also going to be seeing Yi
Wei going up against Nicholas theodoro
who maybe had an opportunity but missed
it here in the last round uh way Yi is
the one that also was able to get the
only score for the Tiger Tigers so far
and finally we will be having a match
between June June and Alice Lee so
there's a lot to look forward to uh we
out it's a pretty equal match on both
boards and Nemo with that we're actually
going to take a little bit of a break
and we'll see what happens when round
two kicks off momentarily
sounds great see you guys soon
[Music]
foreign
chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely days are over
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
oh
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion the St Louis archbishops
Brayton the title back to the chess
capital of the world there
okay there's no eye in chess that said
there's no eye in team either
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
foreign
[Music]
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely days are over
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
look at Bob's burgers
are the champions
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
was
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy
with a new format and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion the St Louis archbishops
Brayton the title back to the chess
capital of the world there
okay there's no eye in chess that said
there's no eye in team either
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
thank you
broadcast
welcome back to round two of the pro
chess League my name is Jonathan trance
I'm joined here by Nemo who is the
captain of our team and we do have round
two underway in the first round the
Tigers were able to get a uh a victory
over us otherwise it was three solid
draws and we're jumping straight into
the game now between linear Dominguez
and uh ji Yi who are playing a game and
Dominguez from the archbishops has the
white pieces he's our highest rated um
player and they are starting we'll get
the board up for you in just a minute
with what else but a Petrov but it's not
a staffer Gambit it's a normal everyday
Grand Master Lee Petrov and we see a lot
of normal moves this is usually a very
solid system for both sides Rook to E1
castles Knight to D2 uh Knight to D6
going back offering a trade of the
Bishops we see Knight going to F1 not
trading immediately and it's a very
solid setup for both of the players we
eventually see the capture on D3 and
here we see H4 though okay and we are
actually going to be getting maybe a
little bit of action here comes the pawn
this is technically a sacrifice I
suppose but maybe not it don't worry
about grabbing this your knight here on
uh D6 might be hanging in the end of the
line so we see the Knight hopping back
black is coming to play a little bit of
defense and white is able to win one of
the Bishops and has to play F6 okay it
looks like not I don't know it's not
like super duper winning or anything for
whites but maybe white is asking a lot
of tough questions here forcing just a
couple minor concessions from the black
side Nemo what do you think of the
position that we got on the board
well I think dominguez's position is
really solid he's got Queen to G3
probably upcoming he's got Knight g393
ideas I really like White's position in
this case and I know you're going to
comment on the fact that it's a
symmetrical Pawn structure again it is
every day I want to remind you guys
right we're getting a lot of symmetrical
Pawn structures and
um that's totally fine so Dominguez has
actually played Knight C3 and it's going
to be going into one of these positions
where
moves will slowly be played on the board
it is a off so as you guys know
when you don't get into the Stafford
Gambit and the Petrov the position is
pretty safe pretty solid but I really
like White's ideas here we've got ideas
like rookie two Rick ae1 we have you
know a lot of ideas with potentially
Pawn to H5 Pawn to H6 just a lot of
things overall like there are all these
little threats that might come up and I
really like this position for white yeah
as well as he doesn't use too much time
that's right most importantly right it
hasn't used too much time but uh yeah
definitely it's looking very promising
for Dominguez and maybe we'll see maybe
this is his approach which is probably
his actual real approach in you know
regular chess match uh try to get some
sort of Advantage with white capitalize
on it and when you have the black pieces
even if you're playing a lower rated
player just play very solid make a draw
if you need to
um but I don't think we'll ever see
Dominguez try to go out of his way to
take like monstrous chances that he
doesn't need to this and this feels
though really like something that he
gets small advantages is like this he's
able to do wonderful things with them so
I definitely want to stay and watch this
one I'm also not sure if any other games
have actually started but I guess we got
our eyes on this waiting to see what
black comes up with
um it's actually uh all of the games
have started and I've started okay
yes and you can go back to events and
click on for example we can go user be
ready the board is about to change all
right so we do have a look out of the
game Benjamin versus
just gonna pop them all up here real
quick whatever you do you know producer
just don't don't put this on the screen
just whatever you do all right now so we
do have all of the games hopefully
uh let's see what else has it looks like
it might be a little bit interesting we
can go to board two now this is the game
between Benjamin Bach and Lou Li ping
this started with an English one to C4
was the starting game uh we see a C6 D5
approach from the opponent so a very
solid way to start but sometimes
sometimes there's dangerous lines here
for white with some early G4 at some
random moments but I don't think we're
going to be seeing that this game white
is just continuing he's developing he's
developing black is able to get the
center we see the trade and we see
Knight to B5 going directly after this
bishop this forces the bishop to go back
to B8 but after Rook to C1 it looks like
it's going to be difficult to stop this
knight from hopping into the C7 Square
so instead we see D4 wait okay there's a
lot of interesting things happening in
this game uh right now fascinating
yeah and I think Louis ping is playing
D4 in order to play uh to e takes D4 for
example if
well I don't suppose that e takes D4
actually works but his plan might be to
try to keep the white king in the middle
of the board with the open E file
however in this case I would just play
Knight B takes D4 and after rakia you
can go Castle because the Knight on D4
is once again protecting the light
squared Bishop so
um you can play e takes softer E4 he
takes D4 e takes D4 all right sorry I
was focusing on being able to get out of
analysis mode after uh I guess after the
capture what were you planning on doing
here at 54 he takes D4 he takes D4 I
wanted to showcase the fact that black
might be trying to play rookie 8 in
order to stop the Y King from castling
but um there is Knight E to D4 right now
which I'm sorry yeah Knight B to D4
and then the lights the night protects
the light Square Bishop after rookie
eight so after rookie eight white can
actually just castle Yeah so this would
look this would be very good for white
just snatched upon for no reason so
let's see what white is actually going
to come up with well oh we actually do
have some moves on the board so this was
played but now instead of capturing the
pawn on D4 we see E4 being the main idea
so sacking upon leaving white with these
isolated pawns and now the Knight hops
in to E5 and would be perfectly happy if
you were willing to take here and fix
our Pawn structure so we'll see what
black is able to come up with and also
we still have this idea of bringing our
Knight into the C7 square at some moment
so this I mean it looks very promising
you're not going to be able to stop
white from being able to Castle if he
wants to and and white might be the one
making all of the threats here in just a
moment
so yeah for sure and honestly I think
black playing A6
um forcing white to play Knight to C7 is
probably his best idea because the
position is just super tight and if you
know black doesn't really get anything
going in this position he's his pieces
are literally all on the back rank he
has to somehow bring his pieces out so
black here plays A6
with Jonathan will demonstrate for us
after Knight to C7 Bishop takes C7
Queen takes C7
um at least black will be able to play
something along the lines I really like
95 personally in this position I think
95 forces Queen takes d8 if you Retreat
your queen
other things might happen and this is
probably going to be Black's best bet he
will be down upon going to this end game
but Benjamin has the double pawns so you
know you can you can deal with that as
black but I do like Benjamin's position
he's definitely slightly better
and in the game actually instead of A6
Knight to B6 has been played
okay which
I do not like at all for black this
looks like
black just is too like his position is
just much too compact right now he needs
to swap off some pieces go into that in
game I like I think Bishop A3 here
rookie eight and then Knight C7 is going
to
um be quite painful yeah I mean so like
taking would be forced I imagine we get
to align something like this and yeah
it's yeah it's just it's a little bit
awkward for black indeed
yeah huh a very tight position for black
so I I trust Benjamin to take care of
the position yeah
yeah and I did want to go back to
dominguez's game really quickly
absolutely because he has played Queen
to H3 and is now pushing H5 possibly
with the idea of pushing H6 yeah we'll
back up just a little bit so he traded a
bishop for a knight on D6 in order to
get this Knight to the F5 Square brings
the queen over uh oh potentially setting
up some nasty cheapos with Knight to H6
so the King has to move over to the
corner now H5 we see one trade of the
Rooks Rook to E8 so black is desperately
trying to get as many pieces traded as
possible
so what will white be able to do if you
can trade all the pieces then the attack
will go away although you know even in
some end game maybe white is doing quite
well here so it'll be interesting to see
what he comes up with
um you know you could just trade Rooks
right away you can even play King to F1
saying if you take my Rook I'm just
gonna take it back with the King look at
that
yeah I dumbing kisses gameplay is just
so safe and so solid so although you
might see the evil bar creeping up a
tiny bit for what I actually have a
feeling that this game is going to be a
draw again because I don't think he's
the type of person to push for a win
we will see come on Dominguez we're down
we're down in the match somebody's got
to step up you got to count on your
highest rated player he's got to come
through but yeah we'll see all right he
does get checked so I'm anticipating
another king move here we'll see where
the king is which direction he wants to
put his King where he feels safest
yeah but I mean absolutely yeah uh we'll
see we'll see
so this one definitely is intriguing uh
also there are there should be quite a
lot of other games decides to put the
King on D2
it is the board one game so we could
stay here for a second definitely not a
deflection yeah I mean that I don't know
how to scan through any other boards
you have them on the side now so you can
just hop over to Wei versus Nicholas
wonderful yes
Nicholas uh we did see this one no we
haven't seen this one at all so Nicholas
theodoro here has the black pieces and
he's going up against the highest rated
opponents on their team so we have some
sort of interesting rosalimo Sicilian
Knight comes out to G6 let's see how
this one shaped up eventual a6b5 whoa
Queens coming over very quickly to H5
caveman style maybe we'll see a quick
Checkmate uh Pawn goes to E5 very solid
keeping that Bishop trapped on C2 but
we'll see is is white actually able to
make use of I don't know some of these
weakened squares he's going to try puts
the Knight on C5 which hurts a little
bit so he's just taken right away we're
seeing the Rooks coming okay Knight to
F4 uh kicks the queen back you have to
keep an eye on some of these pieces lots
of Trades eventual C5 which is what
you're looking to do and are we actually
just losing a pun here though uh oh
is this a is this a major problem for
black
yes this is the major problem for black
unfortunately Nicholas is just blundered
the pawn which to be valid he probably
wasn't even thinking that was the
possibility of the last move uh instead
of playing C5 could have played
potentially yeah maybe you just remove
this move this Rook somewhere or
something
you can definitely play to D7 but even
Rook D7 isn't the best because Rook
takes D7 Queen takes D7 there's Rook to
D1 so you're kind of you're still doing
it if I go back you're gonna do it to me
again
so instead of playing Rick takes D1 uh
sorry instead of playing C5 I'll move
20. he definitely should have just
played
um yeah maybe this is where you know it
started to go wrong yeah this is where
it says you're wrong even F6 looks very
uncomfortable here it's black so that
pawn on E5 just became a weakness oh so
tough luck if we're going to be going
down a pawn here though it's okay he's
trying to get into an end game I think
he's trying to trade the queens and
saying okay you're going to be up a pawn
but we'll get to some end game maybe I
can be solid and try to draw that
somehow but we see way just keeping the
Queens on the board
and some quick moves okay he was ready
for it and he just plops Queen to A5 on
the board some counter attack now I'm a
little bit worried that you know white
is doing some stuff over here on the
king side and we're going to get a
little bit sidelined grabbing some of
these pawns on the other side of the
board usually that's a recipe for
disaster for black but who knows I mean
you just can't even do that you can't
you can't even do that in this position
right because after Bishop Bishop T5
Queen takes a 6a2 there is Rook to D7
straight away hitting your Bishop with
uh so Bishop takes E5 here for white
sorry yep let me just catch up with the
move sorry go ahead again okay I guess
you're going to see it played out on the
board if we take the problem right away
and then there's Rook to D7 oh no which
will hit it just happens immediately
yeah
oh no this would be quite bad so
hopefully we don't go grab this Pawn
right away but if you don't do that what
do you do maybe you need to bring just
try to trade you just need to be a pawn
down and hope for the best
but yeah right
um I mean it's just a very tough
position for Nicholas it's impossible to
play so hopefully you know there's
always a chance that he's able to hold
it but we do have one more game going on
uh this is our game between June Wayne
June versus Alice Lee so our teammate
here has the black pieces and you know
it's tough it's tough when you're the
board four you got to play a lot of good
people and that's the situation she is
in uh playing some sort of King's Indian
attack we're seeing a lot of these like
double fee and ketos and these kinds of
events B6 okay relatively standard
attacks so far where white is usually
like a little bit better in all of these
positions some deep maneuvering black
hoping to eventually be able to play C5
and try to equalize at some moments but
white taking the time to play F4 keeping
the super strong Knight on the E5 Square
lots of interesting maneuvering and
eventually we get to this structure all
right
all right and black is offering a trade
and this is the current position where
Queen to C2 was just played on the board
you know it's it's not so bad at all
there is this weak C Pawn but you know
compared to some of our other boards not
bad at all
yeah
um once again this is just one of those
positions where
it's super solid right now but it feels
like anything can happen we have the
Bishops the darks were Bishops facing
against each other we have flights
tonight on E5 Wyatt has tried to go for
an attack ready with F4 and G4 we might
see an F5 pom push exactly at any given
moment you just never really know what
might happen in these positions I mean
obviously there is the option of uh
black swapping off material with Bishop
takes E5 Bishop takes C4 moves Etc going
into a safer end game but I'm not
entirely sure if Alice feels confident
in this end game where she does have an
isolated Pawn on a half open file with
the pawn on C5 as well as a potentially
weak pot on e4 so this is one of those
really Dynamic positions where I almost
feel like keeping pieces on the board
means that you're signing up to get
attacked but if you're not keeping
pieces
we saw F6 played
right this is exactly uh what I did not
want to see because now there is Rook
takes D5 this could get nasty okay yes
there's Knight to D7
because if you go Rook 67 there's
Bishops yeah
[Music]
okay so yeah let's let's come back to
where we are F6 was played is there
anything else she could do yeah just
Rook takes looks very strong now that
you've put it on the now yeah I mean the
tactics in this position is just
screaming at you right with a pair of
Bishops that white has
oh I can't take but I can't not take
wait this is this yeah because you're
down a piece oh no
yeah it's just not looking great I don't
know if white even to dig back but let's
look strong enough
oh your idea was Knight D2 right 92 was
or 97 sorry it was even stronger oh no
yeah I mean the idea with 97 is simply
that uh the rook's not going anywhere
because if you play anything like Rook
to D6
um you have Knight takes F6 on all these
I mean anyways position is just rough F6
okay so I want to see F6 is uh scary but
she doesn't play it she plays F5
it's still really strong I mean we all
know why Benjamin Feingold told us to
never play F6 right yeah he was totally
right this is this is why he was talking
about this one
but if I chat actually asked our pair of
Bishops better than Knight and Bishop
and for the most case pair Bishops are
better than Knight and Bishops as they
are going to be demonstrated in this
game where the pair of Bishops are just
aimed right at Black's King and you'll
just feel all all sorts of pressure
oh man yeah not easy and all to figure
out so she heads to G5 she's hoping to
be able to use some sort of aggressive
squares in the future but the bishop the
bishop
I mean Rook takes D5 here is still
probably very good
I mean Rook takes D5 is just a free
piece
at this point after Rook takes D5 you
might as well just go Rook D1 we don't
need any of that 97 nonsense anymore
really trapped in the pin if we go ahead
and we try to save it at some point
you're going to be cashing in here and
just winning lots of material oh
it's not good yeah a little a little
iffy all right so I expect to see a
finishing move
uh we actually have some moves now on
the board Rook takes D5 was played and
after Rook takes Rook to D1 exactly this
Rook d8 so all of the analysis it does
appear on the board and now you're in a
tough spot uh Bishop comes in it's
attacking seeing the queen this forces
Rook takes D5 but now Queen to Z4 and
The Rook stays pinned there's just no
way out and now we've run out of ways to
defend our Rook so this could be the
final move uh of the game but we'll see
maybe Alice will battle on maybe she's
she's not ready to resign just yet
okay yeah maybe it's probably the best
bet
all right
we'll see a little bit of a trade here
now you're you're hoping you're just
hoping for some tactic related to this
night coming to F3 but assuming Jew and
June doesn't fall for something like
that
you should be good to go yeah so we
might be watching
I mean there's still a little bit of
fight she's gonna she's gonna put up a
little bit of a fight here
you can take this H Pawn I mean what
lovely stuff
she's definitely trying and I have to
give her credit for that I mean
nothing else to do in this position
other than to play on but there's Rook
takes C5 there's but she takes C5 well
at least there is not Bishop takes E5
you know what I take that because these
are the kinds of things we're waiting
for there it is
exactly exactly maybe this Knight can be
an All-Star
yes but we can't
you know I don't think Julian Jin's
going to fall for that okay she doesn't
so sneaky this is the sneakiest leaving
the pond hanging this is the sneakiest
takes E5 guys still can't take that pawn
nothing has changed from the last
position can't be doing that
um so yeah I mean I don't think Alice is
unfortunately going to be able to hold
this and in other news Dominguez also
just drew his game and I'm getting a
little bit concerned for the lineup now
let me take a very quick peek at this
because we saw it looked like mildly
promising up to here and then he just
trades the Queens
look at this slight Advantage into the
end game very professional who who
offered the draw and who accepted it
come on keep playing we're trying to win
we need to make up points
um so that's how this game finished we
can take another quick look at the
Benjamin Bot game I know we've had quite
a lot of moves here oh this one was
interesting let's just run this back
from the top we'll we'll speed run
through the uh the opening here because
we got to a position like this and this
one looked the most promising for white
so if we want to look at what a
potentially good position for us we saw
up to about here Knight comes into D5
where it goes all the way back to C1
white is up a pawn
uh but now okay a little bit
uncomfortable we got to bring our guy
back kick this night out very
interesting Pawn structure going on on
the D file here's F3 getting the guy out
of the way some trades let's get all
these Rooks off the board they were
making it complicated picking up the
pawn on A3 Knight's getting kicked away
but this looks very promising for white
indeed looks like we're even winning
this Pawn
it is an opposite colored Bishop end
game but
I did that I thought this had a little
bit more promise at some points but
still still hopefully we're able to get
there okay now our last move was D5
removing the defender of B5 and I guess
if we're able to get these two outside
passers maybe everything is actually
going to be lovely for us I mean not
even that if uh King takes D5 you know
we just simply have D7 yeah that's also
a major problem for the opponent so I
guess we won't be seeing that one so the
king will probably need to go back we're
going to win this pawn and this actually
I guess that makes it a very easy win
for white let's get some points on the
board it does lowie ping did indeed
resign all right and that will be
Benjamin box win uh which is great as
it's needed very lovely stuff uh have we
seen anything of this game we did okay
so this is we are black in this one this
is Nicholas theodoro
um this is the toughest matchup for us
oh yeah this is the one where we were
down like a pawn uh at some point oh we
blundered upon and then Rook d8 was
played hoping to get some sort of
simplification needing to avoid getting
checkmated need to have whoa wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait what the heck
is happening
so after E5 was played I don't know
perhaps the queen is getting ready to
come over to F5 we see Bishop takes G2
what is this this should take G2 is very
ambitious and again it's these sneaky
nights I guess if you're going here
right I mean once again we're not for
cheapos if we're if we're already down
you know however many points I might as
well scope for them it was like Bishop
takes two maybe a way you won't see King
games oh I think he saw it yeah
okay makes the bishop hey but we took
your bun oh no the garban and now if we
take back the whole thing is collapsing
so we play Knight to G5 okay maybe our
Cheapo didn't work you can't you can't
get away with this uh oh another sneaky
infotrado
oh wait I just geeky though it is quite
sneaky forces
right Wade is making mistakes a pin um
with only six seconds left
we're able to get back in time hey pokes
the rook and now eventually maybe he's
finally capitalizing on this we've
grabbed a lot of stuff in the meantime
while you were busy winning our night so
I mean it can't possibly be that good
for black but we've gotten up to this
point and I mean I don't know it was at
least a sneaky and good effort there
yeah he tried and now we're I mean now
we're in the the time scramble so
you can see both of these players are
racing with not a lot of time left so
really anything is possible now
we have one less Bishop but you know two
extra pawns three extra pawns
theoretically Fair
theoretically fair and also you know
it's it's not that easy to play these
kind of positions for a win with the
white pieces so there's always an
opportunity that Nicholas is able to
hold this to a draw I mean he's pushing
the pawns he's doing the thing he has to
go King G6 here or you know don't
disregard what I said I said I had to go
King G6 because this is what I was
afraid of now your king looks like it's
getting quite turned away for one second
what was happening oh no the pawn oh no
you need to keep the puns
we're so close we're so close yeah I
mean I mean there's no light squared
Bishop on the board that pawn would
basically be promoting next move you
know yeah it is hard to move the pawn
now so the pawn gets stuck
we're gonna lose that H bonds you might
as well like let's get three pawns on
the other side go upon scope this is
actually
um
if it wasn't for the fact that White's
King I mean yeah the white King was so
far pushed up it's so active it would
probably be actually closer to a draw
than you can imagine white moved a
little bit but yeah there we go there's
only one bishop
and there goes the rug oh that's
actually the last that's probably the
last move of the game oh no yeah so
Benjamin Bach wins the game but then
Nicholas theodoro here loses the game so
that keeps us on even and it's I guess
the Dominguez game was a draw so the
only thing we need to know is Alice Lee
who was in trouble
um in this game she has the uh the white
pieces here let's try to remember where
we saw last we saw okay we saw all of
this for sure we'll just come back and
run through these moves oh yeah she was
just totally busted in a lot of trouble
but she had a sneaky night we haven't
seen a sneaky night do anything great
yet but look at that King look at that
wait what is happening look at that King
wait what
this is this is the major comeback hey
Alice Lee
wait Alice Lee She's the greatest she
has to play Pawn to E3 she has to play
Pawn to E3 the idea behind Pawn to E3 is
the Knight to F2
um and if Bishop takes F2 Pawn takes F2
yeah or even King takes after I'm not
even sure there but you got promotion
ideas at the very least wait Ellis Lee
no no no you can't play Knight takes F6
because after Rook takes A7 the A6 Pawn
is too close to promotion so now you no
longer have this resource
idea oh yeah I mean she was so scared of
this F Bond and I would be too right but
now your night is too far
the difference between the F bond is
that if the F-bomb promotes it doesn't
have any idea direct checks the problem
with 8 I'm promoting is that it promotes
into a check yeah oh so you're losing uh
yeah you're losing too much time
so she saw the idea of a wrong execution
which is very unfortunate and we could
see the eval bar she was definitely
winning there for just a moment she had
her a chance one move another chance
slipping away we can't just you know we
can't throw away all of our games we've
been having enough chances yeah haven't
fully capitalized this far into the
round
all right H2 sure I love it but at some
points King is blockading the H Pawn
whenever we make a queen they're just
gonna trade and then it's white making a
queen and stopping us from doing
anything
so okay very unfortunate we'll hold out
hope that for some some Swindle some
stalemate some Fortress
yeah dress with with Bishop versus queen
you know there's actually an um
I don't know if you know this but there
is a rook Pawn King Fortress and that's
the only Fortress that you have against
the queen every other position is lost
against a queen including this one this
is where this game has come to an end
so very very sad for the archbishops so
we've lost
uh how many did we lose this round we
won one we lost two so that puts two and
a half to one and a half yeah we started
two and a half one and a half in their
favor
and now I think they're gaining even
more things are slipping away we need a
very strong round three and four here
it's currently five to three
five to three first to eight and a half
total games okay Mercedes correct
yeah so they could the other team could
theoretically clinch the Tigers here
could theoretically clinch in the next
round although that would be kind of
preposterous but you know maybe we're
just the second half team you know I
know Mike cummer when he puts together
the teams he likes to make it you know a
little bit of drama he's a big football
fan maybe yeah he's setting us up he
watched the Super Bowl he saw the Chiefs
come back he's like you know what let's
set up our own little comeback and we'll
take he's making it exciting absolutely
and with that we will be back with some
exciting coverage of round three we're
gonna head into just another break here
but uh stay with us because it's only
going to get more exciting from here
foreign
chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely days are over
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
[Music]
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
face
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion the St Louis archbishops
Brayton the title back to the chess
capital of the world there
okay there's no eye in chess that said
there's no eye in team either
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
[Music]
in the world
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely days are over
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
[Music]
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
oh my God
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion the St Louis archbishops
Brayton the title back to the chess
capital of the world there
okay there's no eye in chess that said
there's no eye in team either
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
foreign
that was an amazing piece of calculation
for easily dominated his Rivals when he
win a game the opposition has never been
as needed as fiercely over the league
chess tournaments in the world
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely days are over
the pro chess league is back
foreign
[Music]
you're on
and you can see here the results from
round two we are covering the St Louis
archbishops going up against the
Shanghai Tigers you can see in the final
round uh the second round that we just
witnessed Dominguez Perez has now made a
draw with uh Julie Benjamin Bach was
able to score our first win for the team
against Lou yaping Nicholas theodoro was
unlucky against uh way Yi and Alice Lee
was unable to at she went from losing to
winning to losing against jewwayne June
a lot was possible there but
unfortunately it does result uh in a
five to three lead for the Tigers I'm of
course joined with Nemo who is our
captain on our team and has been helping
us with our coverage of the event uh
Nemo are you are you are we going to
bounce back in round three what's gonna
happen
I mean at this point we have lost two
matches and as far as I have been told
the score itself doesn't matter so even
though we are down two points
technically we have we just have to win
the next two matches and that can be
totally doable yeah I have faith in us I
think there's a lot of chances here
we've got this game against uh between
Dominguez and Zhu and Jun at some point
today Dominguez you know not not that
draws are not good for us but draws are
not contributing to the scoreboard just
yet so he might step it up you know it's
still early for him as well and this
might just be his warm-up game and we
can actually go into this game yeah
let's jump into it so Dominguez here has
the black pieces going up against you
Wayne June so far only two draws from
our highest rated player let's see what
he's able to come up with is he just
going to remain strictly solid with the
black pieces go for some sort of ragozen
and with Queen to A4 and we'll see the
exact line that he chooses so again this
is known to be a very solid line D takes
C4 this is all like kind of main main
line Theory I'm actually a little bit
concerned because I know there's a lot
of draw lines in these but we see Pawn
to E5 usually this is how you try to
equalize with the black pieces F4 is
played at some Moments White is able to
secure the two Bishops and this is
actually where we are the game is just
starting to get interesting so uh in a
Dream World for whites you know you're
able to get castled and eventually
you're able to move all these things but
it is black to move and hopefully he's
able to come up with something good and
interesting to keep the game going from
this position what are your thoughts on
the opening Choice here by Dominguez
I think the opening itself is very safe
um which you know playing as black
it's the correct way to go
um and at the same time you're keeping
her a couple of opportunities open for
yourself when you're entering this kind
of middle game however I am a little
concerned about Pawn to G6 in this
position where white light squared
Bishops are you know just aimed right at
last thing again I'm a little concern
about this the Beggars have figured out
the the recipe for Success just point
your Bishops at the king and it's been
working out really you know peer
pressure feels so strong yeah februshes
are just so strong it's a very classic
idea in chess I don't I don't see why it
wouldn't work otherwise
um you know in this case I actually
would like Dominguez to be
drawing the game we might even call him
Dominguez
um it'll be it'll be good for him to
draw this game I already don't like
Black's position very much so uh I don't
actually know if you ever see the board
did they see the board oh yes they
should be seeing the board and I think
what we're hoping for here is black is
that like you're hoping to be able to
conquer these this E4 Square it looks
like maybe he's trying to play with
Bishop to F5 this Rook can come to E8
maybe he can get some sort of pressure
and eventually this epon becomes weak
but I think the question then becomes
does white have time to just play E4 now
or do you need to prioritize castling
but uh we will see I guess exactly what
they come up with because there's also
the chance that you're able to play here
and at some point get castled and just
start steamrolling down the board uh
with some sort of devastating attack so
it's it's going to come down to a few
Tempe here
it's going to be an interesting game for
sure I I'm really curious as to how
um Junction continues this game she
might be feeling still a little bit
shaky last game where she was you know
completely winning but uh did give Alice
Lee a chance so that does mean her
tactics might not be entirely all the
way up there for his evening for her
might not be entirely all the way up
there
um in this like you know the airplane on
the opposite side of the world so for us
it's very early in the morning but for
them maybe they're they're getting tired
you'd think that would give us an
advantage I don't know how many of our
players are you know morning I don't
know Birds if you're a night owl
I personally prefer playing chess way
late during the day like yeah if I could
play Chess at 2AM I guess everybody else
it probably that probably my winning
strategy but on it but unfortunately
they do not host Chester events past 3
P.M apparently the standard last round
time oh at least in Europe is 3 P.M
um and somebody in my chat was actually
saying G6 seems strange to my amateur
eye yeah and you have to realize that
when you are a grand master
you don't really see things the same way
that other people do Dominguez in this
position is playing G6 because he is
confident that there is going to be no
threats along the G file uh sorry G them
h8 to a one diagonal for now and really
wanted to put out the F5 the bishop to
F5 as Jonathan has said and in this case
you know you can always just defend your
B7 pawn and nothing is going to happen
on the dark squares at least for now
yeah that's the key word you just don't
know later what might happen
so positionally this is a small
accomplishment here for black I like it
we got the E4 Square meaning this E3
Pawn might be you know Frozen in a
Target in the future now we see him
actually giving up a pun the queen went
to B3 which prevents us from ever you
know putting a rook on E8 it also
attacks this Pawn but here he's just
willing to give up this bee Pawn
so I guess the idea is if you if you're
taking you're going to be grabbing this
guy and trying to end up with a lot of
compensation and you know what maybe
it's right maybe you're able to go here
and put your Bishop on e4 and this is
the kind of thing that he's hoping to
get into and something like that
actually might turn out really well for
him
and I did want to say that all of the
games have now started don't forget
we're doing a staggered start so we can
go to the all right events page really
quick button and our producers
don't worry about it let's just show the
people what you know what's going on
it's all right yes so we've got way
paired up against Benjamin Bach which is
going to be a really exciting one
wonderful so Benjamin Bach has the black
pieces here we can go ahead and jump
into this game going up against Wei not
easy wait a minute might we get a Gambit
no had the potential for a scotch Gambit
now we're just gonna play the center
game which is also kind of a rare
opening That You Don't See too too often
Bishop yeah I feel like you are so close
to getting gambits in a lot of grand
Masters but then everybody at the very
last second is like no I'm not going to
staff for Gambit no I'm not going to
Center Gambit like you get super baited
when because you just know if you're
playing a blitz or epic game and
somebody placed an opening like that you
know that C3 move is happening next
there's no 360 for C3 you give out the
B2 Pawn you play Bishop C4 you play
Queen B3 like you you know exactly what
happens but at this level
we don't see that because everybody
knows Theory presumably and look I am a
little bit excited though because we
have something we don't usually see we
have an imbalance in the pawn structure
and maybe more importantly we got
castling on opposite sides someone might
be trying to win this game
somebody might be trying to win this
game and honestly I think Benjamin Buck
is that person because it is going to an
unbalanced Pawn structure for you know
one of the first times ever we don't
have a symmetrical Pawn structure where
castling on different sides there's
always the opportunity of A6 B5 and B4
hitting white with that you know Pawn
advance and especially since white
already has a hook on A3 that's what we
call when the pawn is pushed up on one
of the sides of the board and you can
play b5p4 into it
so a lot of ideas over here yeah
definitely it'll be interesting to see
how black does it will it be with Asics
will you start with a rook will you just
Gambit upon with B5 at some moments just
go in for it uh and then there's also
like slow Maneuvers to consider I would
assume also black maybe is having on his
mind okay maybe I can maneuver a night
it's exactly what he's going for
maneuvering this Knight towards the C4
square and I'd expect you know at some
point white is going to be trying to set
up some sort of Defense both of these
players probably anticipating uh the
attacks coming from one another so it'll
be kind of interesting to see how this
one
uh does shake up here
so this is exciting this is where we
might get some attacking chess we're
we're going to go into an exciting game
for sure
um and another exciting game might
actually be the game between Alice Lee
and Shu Yi who
you know Ellis
is bouncing back from a tough loss last
round where she was
winning for one move for sure but
winning nonetheless against Jew and Jin
which is you know really impressive
really impressive and I really like your
position in this situation they've also
Castle on opposite sides let's go we're
trying to win all right we've been
joking it's time to put our Fortune gas
here
yeah for sure I love F4 I love the fact
that the H file is half open blacks King
is very very slightly weak I wouldn't go
ask first to call it a week because you
know the white king itself is on a
potentially open file next move if black
just plays C5 which in this situation
they can't because you know Knight takes
D5 is a thing but but now maybe ideas
yeah now you know what I spoke that
didn't exists as maybe I do like VTEC C3
it's better than Queen takes C3 because
after Queen takes C3 C5 was going to be
the move potentially and you just never
know about these kind of positions so I
like B takes E3 you might be like oh but
the king's even weaker but do keep in
mind black does not have a dark squared
bishop or Bishop at all
so White's King is safe for now yeah
it'll be interesting to see how does
white continue to try to make some sort
of inroads in will she try to do
something directly in the center will
she try to load up on the H file will
she try to maneuver this Knight closer I
mean I think it's it's kind of a
difficult situation because you like how
do you make progress with white uh oh
there's a lot of ideas that are possible
sometimes it can be difficult to come up
with just the right one
well I think the right idea in this
position is to just bring your pieces
over so something like Knight to F3
makes a lot of sense potentially you
know like doubling her Rooks on the H
file you also do want to play Knight of
three in order to play 95 at some point
in case that E3 Pawn gets threatened
just you know keeping its uh sort of
solid is honestly not bad here because
Black's King's not really going anywhere
there's there's not many places for it
to go
and it looks like I mean so black is not
necessarily trying to even open up the
queen side which was maybe the idea
behind C5 rather we're going to see a
focus on the center and I think at some
moment black would like to be able to
maneuver the other night all the way
into the E4 Square so we could end up in
a situation with two very strong Knights
for either player but the Knight on e4
really will be difficult for white to
remove to remove but that is a long way
from happening Knight to F3 is on the
board
we do have Knight to F3 Alice Lee is
playing really well absolutely he was
playing really well
she's one of the the most underrated
Superstars she's played here at the
chess club quite a few times at this
point and for some reason everyone's
always like wait she actually plays
really well like at some point the world
will take notice and be like oh wait
yeah she's actually a really good player
she's she's a sleeper for sure
yeah at 13 being 23 20 is quite
a feat for sure
um also means you know you have a lot
more years of chest left than you which
is the most important bar for chess
remember the name Alice Lee
yeah place your bets now
how does she look we've just pulled her
up on this ring how did she look
I can never tell if is she nervous is
she just calm I could never it's hard to
read her body language
yeah I think I think she's just chilling
she's just playing she's just playing
the game and she's just playing chess uh
direct to eat
I thought the night was going there The
Rook comes in
trying to double but yeah the engine did
not like it for some reason and G F
takes G5 is played on the board is this
are we just tearing up the H file wait a
minute what is happening yeah Rick to H5
she she's got the idea of Ricky Rick H1
sorry Rick take a she five is happening
a lot of moves holy cow yeah black
probably needs to be very careful now
how do you how do you defend everything
all at once I guess you need to make a
counter attack against the E Pawn
and white will decide are you going to
the H file are you going to defend your
e-pawn are you going to take this G Pawn
a lot of stuff going on here things are
wait this is a very tense moment
it for sure is I feel like
I mean this position can't be that
difficult for Alice I I have a lot of
confidence in her uh once again usually
younger players enjoy attacking
absolutely so you know Rook dth1 is a
very logical move here you actually
don't necessarily want to play Rook
takes G5 it might look really tempting
to go for that Free Pawn but there is
King to f8 and the King actually ends up
running and you don't really want that
in this position because although you're
temporarily you're not even up upon at
this moment so that disregard that
you're not even up online and it's
actually white that might suffer from a
bad structure right well White's gonna
suffer from a bad structure there's no
reason to go for that so you do actually
just want to play Rook D to H1 okay so
let's see maybe she'll come up with this
move
yeah or rookie one I think either one is
pretty okay protect your Pawn make some
counter threats we'll see I do want to
stay here just a moment I think the next
couple moves she takes with a night
night takes G5
so attacking The Rook but basically
you're inviting The Rook to take so that
maybe the queen can sweep in I don't see
there's no mate or anything but it looks
like I mean it looks scary if you're
playing with black moving once my queen
comes in
right after work takes E3 there's Queen
H7 there's King f8 uh I don't even know
what's happening off of that a lot of
things yeah so this is the kind of
position that we could be looking for
maybe you get here and you go oh wait
there was nothing all along but you know
it is a bit spooky
so we'll see what black comes up with
I don't know how black does anything
else in order to avoid that
because without you know sacking in
exchange which seems unlikely
yeah excellent definitely so we got to
keep our eyes on this one we'll keep a
look at Alice Lee there is one game that
we haven't looked at yet and it's the
game between uh Nicholas theodoro here
with the white pieces going up against
Lou yipping and let's see what we what
this one's all about this could be our
round though
um
we needed to be around
looks like a very standard one of these
kinds of positions it's usually slightly
better for white which you know what we
can take we do see a pawn sacrifice here
though at some moments in order to
prevent black from Ever playing C5 but
black says you know what I'm my own
person I'll play C5 if I want to and
then after a series of Trades a big long
series of traits
we've arrived at this position where G4
was the move just played okay
so everything is I mean it it feels very
similar but I don't know hopefully that
black king is feeling a little bit
weaker than the white king this is
huh
it looks yeah Queen D2 I think there's
Queen to D6
um you might want to bring your queen in
definitely white slightly better here
there is a symmetrical Pawn structure
but I would say white but black is the
one that's pushed them all and if black
is in checkmating then you've just
pushed all your pawns up the board for
no reason we see Queen to be exactly
immediately targeting his Ebon
has something caught your eye have we do
we need to go to another game
I mean sorry White's approaching this
position right now he's taking it really
slow black has all of these weak pawns
so one of the things that when you're
put on has weak pawns you have to
remember to attack them right and that's
exactly what Nicholas is doing with
Queen tips
Rook to G4 potentially attacking the G4
Pawn the 995 is now a little stuck you
might he might want to play Queen D1
swap like you know
the placement of the queen and the Rook
so then there's also Queen uh Rook to
d6th ideas a lot of a lot of things
there's so many potential targets just
kind of lurking in this position whereas
white is very solid so I like our
chances here in this game it might be
very holdable for black but
if anybody cracks here it's got to be
black
Queen to C2 okay just threatening to
come in
okay
so we're just saying
he's you know he's fishing he's trying
to get the king to go back
moves played
oh no sorry there were some music by the
way let's go almost like uh Rook takes
A3
yeah after Knight takes G5 we see Rook
takes E3 this was played so she gets her
Queen into the position we weren't quite
finding some mate she goes all the way
back uh oh watch out for this one queen
queen comes in so now on some check the
king is gonna have to start running away
but we see a queen trade uh and this is
our position that we find ourselves in
after uh F takes G6 okay
yeah I think this is one of those
positions where once again uh anything
can still happen although
we do have a lot of bonds hanging yeah
we have a lot of content in this game I
mean although the engine doesn't love
White's position anymore
not not because black can just take on
G3 and stuff like that that that doesn't
seem like the best idea
um but because Rick 8 to E7 potentially
trying to swap off The Rook means that
you will be going into an end game uh in
which it favors black so that's our
biggest worry as white here you still
want to keep up your initiative you
don't want to swap off pieces and go
into the end game yeah end games are not
going to be good for white here so how
will she keep this Rook on the board
I don't think I don't think I can I
think she has to play Rook of one and
just swap it off but at least the end
game is a draw and for Alice drawn
against somebody who is like you know
200 points higher rated than her is
really good as well
so there's no problem
there
um and if Alice holds and Nicholas might
potentially get a win and we might
actually want to jump around to
Benjamin's game we haven't tuned since
we've taken a look it looks like quite a
lot of stuff has happened right uh this
is the opposite side castling game
might want to swap the board really
quick as well if it doesn't look right
we did swap the colors yeah but okay
here comes white G5
okay the Knight is getting a little
stranded you got to play G6 wait excuse
me
ah okay so there's an attack on the base
and the queen yeah Knight to D5 so you
have to take that guy because your queen
was attacked then you see this recapture
instead of recapturing on E5 the the
white Bishop just drops back white is
trying to push through black was trying
or black is trying to go for you know a
little attack on the A3 Square uh we got
these pawns these pawns are rolling
they're a bit blockaded
we're seeing a lot of sacrifices white
sacks upon in order to get the queen on
this diagonal F6 is played yet again not
with the idea of ever recapturing that
pawn we're trying to keep this Pawn in
the way of the Queens alignment here and
we're gonna wait what is happening
where's this King going wait where are
you going oh no wait what happened was
what happened just here was this I guess
yeah I mean this movie
this nasty queen move maybe this was I
don't know where it went wrong
I'm not sure I'm not sure why the A7
Palm was just left there yeah so it
looks like yeah this this is time
trouble I I think it's time trouble but
something here had to be different
you had to find a way to protect his
Pawn
but instead oh so many close games oh
the queen is coming in
that's very unfortunate
so yeah just hoping for a queen swap
which would make life a little bit
better but these puns I mean they got so
far but they're easily blockaded by the
pieces and more importantly this this
King can get in danger especially if the
Queens stay on the board the Queen takes
on H7 and then we got Bishop takes D1
so
yeah even if white doesn't do anything
more than just thinking back like it
looks like what is black even doing
okay yeah let's we can stay here a
second try to figure it out they've
entered into that speed portion so
hopefully Anything is Possible
but now it looks like uh excuse me right
we just we lost the queen
yeah yeah okay well it takes you cannot
take back with the King you got to take
with your rook and then oops
that loses a queen unfortunately that
will not be Benjamin box game oh no we
caught the we caught this one at a wrong
time that's another loss for the St
Louis archbishops uh with that being
said we didn't take a huge look at the
Dominguez game but okay we can run we'll
super speed run back through this and
this one we were we had the black pieces
as well this game ended in a draw we saw
up to about here uh we did think that it
was around equal and it turns out the
players agreed another opposite colored
Bishop this is this is about is drawn as
it gets a little bit of mild hope here
for black but this game eventually
petered out nobody was able to make any
progress here's the ultra speed run
there you go I I feel like I'm going to
where we might need to start a
nicknaming Topanga's drawing guess
you might not even he might not even
mind it that much he might yeah I'm
solid you know how Anish giri always
draws and that's like his meme I I feel
like Dominguez is close to that as well
in fact even more so than
um Anish giri his games have been super
solid it's been
yeah it's been absolutely equal all the
way through yeah I think he's probably
very proud of his solid Style We turned
now to our game against Nicholas
theodoro
uh this one black is
looks like somehow at some point here
maybe outplayed us again this is looking
bad for the team you really peps me up
though you gave this little little Dean
pep talk Captain style and I was I was
getting excited about this round what's
happening right I don't I don't actually
know I mean it feels like we have all of
the players it feels like the games were
going really well it just feels like on
the execution level a couple of things
are missing and also
you know Dominguez drawing well up 200
points is not helping the rest of the
team necessarily but I still have a lot
of faith this is once again only the
first round so if you lose three games
you're out you have to win sorry not you
have to win three matches in order to
stay in the league if you lose three
matches you are out of the league
absolutely so we're really looking for
white to somehow be able to hold this we
still have a chance in this this match
but it's by the by the game it seems to
be slipping away but it really it's a
tale of just a lot of missed chances so
I'm hoping Mike Hummer you know when he
has the team meeting he yells at some of
these guys and you know lets them know
we gotta win when we have these kinds of
positions
yeah and unfortunately I have to tell
you that Alice Lee oh don't tell me
also losing no say it's not true what
happened to Alice
oh yeah he's not got into a good
position
yeah it looks like the kind of position
where if you you didn't actually end up
with the Checkmate you might have ended
up in the worse end game and maybe
that's happened exactly so yeah and that
has totally happened
um
yes
I still believe
I said nice things about her I hope that
we can't let this you know
is there going to be a fourth round
after
yeah so no matter what I think you do
play every single round
so even if they've they've technically
won
got it so uh but we're still we still
got some hope here in Alice you never
know
all right these tricky nights you never
but uh yeah so just to kind of recap
this round it was Dominguez with another
draw theodoro had a draw Bach lost to
Wei Yi and now the last game going on is
this game with Alice where we're also in
a little bit of trouble we're gonna have
to like win out it's gonna have to be
like a clean sweep in the last round
I haven't run the math on it but I'm
feeling like we need to win a we need to
win everything from here
all right this looks bad you're nice
yeah
it's looking it's looking a little rough
I can't believe he's playing all the way
to the end she always does I'm pretty
sure no she does come on Alice you're
making me look bad yeah she's just
resigned you don't mind at all like you
said like it's
it's play Until the End especially
I just never know what might happen now
I have a lot of respect for that I was
just I was just saying you know she
actually is one too and he's uh she
comes to a lot of the junior
championships the U.S women's
championships these kinds of big events
and G is always playing to the very very
bitter end and people are like wait why
is she still playing it's been over it's
mate in one like no she just plays all
the way to the end especially in these
long ones okay I guess even this
position was too much she's decided uh
to throw in the towel here which makes a
little bit of sense so uh if we are to
win this I have been told that we
actually do need to sweep in the final
round so I don't know if you believe in
miracles but we will see if it happens
in round four we are going to take a
quick break here Nemo do you have any
words for the team before we head into
the break
honestly we just have to play good chess
that's it that's the best that we can do
I just want to see some really good
games we've had a lot of great games
today some beautiful tactics some you
know really interesting interesting
games but unfortunately the score is
just not there and we just need to score
all right if you believe in comebacks
make sure you come back for round four
we'll be with you in just a moment
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to St Louis where we are
eagerly getting ready for the fourth and
final round of the first week of the pro
chess League we are doing coverage for
the St Louis archbishops who are in a
bit of a dire spot Nemo we need to win
every single game a draw will not cut it
anymore do they have any chance of
clinching this match as we go into the
last round
honestly I feel like trying to say that
we're going to get a 4-0 is going to be
a little bit you know complicated but I
have faith that we will at least be able
to
get get a few points I I just want to
finish strong I want to feel like I want
the team to feel like we have a chance
in all of our upcoming matches I mean
for a first round
for for a first round opponent this was
just like really a really really really
strong team so not much to be done about
that we're trying our best and all all
things otherwise
you know whatever happens happens and
there's still four more chances
technically to make it into the playoffs
absolutely and we're gonna have to hope
for the best here we can get a little
reminder of what just happened in uh
round three you guys were able to see we
don't even want to talk about it anymore
okay you know when you're when you're in
the fourth quarter you can't worry about
what happened in the rest of the game
you just got to show up and try your
best and hopefully uh that is what we're
gonna see here so we are waiting for um
the first game two actually starts for
the rounds but I believe we have it and
we're going to be able to catch this one
pretty early the first game that we have
and this is where all of the All-Stars
will be playing we got lenier Dominguez
going up against Wei Yi in the final
round Dominguez has the white pieces
which is great Benjamin Bach will be
going up against June Wayne June this is
another Benjamin Bach must win to keep
us in contention additionally we will
also be looking forward to seeing
uh the game between Yi Zhu and Nicholas
theodoro Nicholas will be needing to win
with black he's had some chances in this
tournament he's maybe the one that's
been playing the most for the win so
hopefully we can count on him today in
our final match that we will be looking
forward to is yipping Lou versus Alice
league and Alice come through with the
black pieces well let's start it off
with board one let's get straight to our
game with Dominguez he has yet to win
today he's been very solid he's been
making lots of draws you know what
usually that cuts it but this round it's
not going to get it done he's going up
against Wei Yi and this game kicked off
with E4 E5 Knight F3 Knight to C6 and we
get a rui Lopez please do not play the
Berlin please play D3 and just do
anything to try to keep this game alive
I like the fact that you also don't like
the Berlin the Berlin definitely has
some of my biggest reasons this is such
a fantastic opening minus the Berlin
look I get it you know but a draw here
is not gonna cut it there's no time for
these things Bishop G5 actually strikes
me as a bit odd and I think maybe he is
just trying to play something not like
too off the wall but I mean this strikes
me as not necessarily like this looks
like a beginner type of move getting the
bishop out before you move the Knight
but maybe he's just goading he's trying
to get a different kind of position uh
we'll see especially he's slightly
offbeat I'm sure B5 is a is a line here
and I I actually remember playing as
white into a line with B5 and I didn't
really like the positions but I'm not
entirely sure what Dominguez is looking
for here once again Dominguez is very
very familiar with openings he's been a
second for a lot of really strong Grand
Masters
um he was a second for Fabiano Carana
during the I believe it was a 2018 World
Championship match so he's familiar with
these kind of positions absolutely I
tend to trust this opening prep well
yeah absolutely do you think I mean in
an event like this though I often wonder
are we getting the best you know is he
saving his good stuff for the real
tournaments and he's like okay here's
just some like off-ball line you know
I'll just play like Bishop G5 and you
know if you play H6 I'll drop back and
we'll just play some some sort of
different position I'm not sure if we
get to see the absolute best stuff in a
tournament like this but sometimes the
odd stuff is a lot more fun to watch
for sure and I think we've all seen a
million Berlin's I think we've all seen
a million of the same you know Spanish
whichever lines the Briars or the
Marshalls it's always nice to see
something a little bit offbeat
um it's always great to just
and this looks a lot more familiar like
an average this is like you're just
you're just at the chess club you're
just right here at the club somebody's
playing this right here we're just
maneuvering the pieces playing a game of
chess we'll see how some of the top
players in the world are able to handle
it so we saw H6 Bishop to H4 now the
bishop is dropped all the way back to uh
A6 you know just making sure at some
point white will be trying to play D4
not necessarily here with the E4 hanging
but black is just getting the bishop out
of the way not committing to castling I
think white is waiting like please show
me that you're gonna castle and black
says Nah let's just wait a little bit
let's see what you're gonna do first and
there might be a little bit of cat and
mouse going on in this game I do think I
have some of the other games here but
just a reminder we do need a win on
every single board so hopefully we come
back and we see something good now this
is Benjamin Bach going up against June
Wayne June uh we have the white pieces
here a potential for a cattle on but
instead we're getting one of these like
reverse benoni kind of positions you
know what
not a not a bad way to try to play for a
win we get B4 not necessarily
sacrificing a pawn because in some lines
the e-pawn would be hanging
so let's see exactly what happens well
here we might be
playing a Gambit I guess not because if
Bishop takes back there's always the
Rook taking on the E5 square and yeah
this is okay this looks like an
interesting and potentially promising
way to continue this could be a good one
if you need to try to win you know what
I think we got a good opening here what
do you think of this one
yeah I 100 agree I think this position
is basically it looks a lot like a
benoni somehow for white but obviously
with reverse colors uh I do like this
position a lot from why I think the E5
fonts is going to be super weak like you
mentioned and also the E4 Square might
potentially be really true so black has
a solution of her own oh you oh it's
going to be weak is it okay I push E4
now what do you say
wow I just say I'm going to play Rook to
B1
um
with your night hanging defending yeah
but I'm defending my before night
so if he takes F3 then I'll just take on
E8 and then I can take on
um F3 with my Bishop and then after that
there will be just simply a weak D4 Pawn
that black has and I don't mind playing
this position at all with the white
pieces holy cow all right wait we could
be up to something good then if we can
find a move like Rook to B1
absolutely I mean even if you don't play
Rook B1 Knight to C2 I think preserving
the
other night is much more important
because once again anytime he plays he
takes F3 you're winning the pawn right
so yeah uh winning the Palm back
technically
so that's totally fine
okay so we have got some moves I think
your move was chosen Knight to C2 and
after takes we saw The Rook trade first
followed by Bishop takes F3 Bishop to C5
protecting the pawn is now followed up
with Rook to B1
and this looks phenomenal
I like Benjamin's position
I have confidence in him he can
definitely play a position like this for
a win at least push it for a win so it's
looking it's looking good it's a good
start so far wonderful so we'll
definitely come back and take a look at
this we'll see if Benjamin Bach can
somehow pull this one out we also need a
win on this board with the black pieces
we have Nicholas theodoro he is going up
against uh Zhu Yi and they have a
sicilian Sicilian is a good go-to if you
gotta win
all right this is probably some Theory
B4 wait what is white tried to win oh
this is this is some funky stuff here we
go this is what we like to see if we
need a win
let's see B5 played shutting the night
out maybe we can make use at some point
of this C4 square but maybe white is
trying to break through F5 all right F5
was the last move played potentially
trying to get some action on this f file
this could be a dangerous attack
what do you think indeed I I honestly
like this uh everybody knows they have
to play for a win so I respect the fact
that everyone is going for the win
F5 is great if you have e takes F5 you
obviously have Rook takes F5 and then
you can bring your Rook over and Y would
probably not do that so a white hat does
have to answer this position I'm not
really sure what what White's gonna do F
takes E4 is a very real threat next move
yeah so something like this
I mean this is just fantastic for us
yeah what is what do you even do if you
have white
it's a hard question really not sure I
like I like black if I don't know what
to do with white it means I like black
so I mean a miracle it could be America
that's what we're looking for exactly a
miracle
and we do have one more game that we
would also need to keep our eyes on and
this is the game with Alice Lee so she
has the black pieces going up against uh
Lou ye ping also a sicilian also a
rosalimo but a little bit of a different
variation perhaps this is a little bit
more traditional okay uh all right we
get kind of a typical structure for this
white is trying to trade off the dark
squared Bishops coming into these
squares you know it's a very solid
approach but sometimes
is this the I don't know if this is the
best way to play for a win but you know
what I trust in Alice I think Alice she
knows what she's up to what do you think
I agree with you I feel like Alice
hasn't had the best event thus far
sure it's open only three games for her
but
she's probably she's probably really
really really wants that win so she's
going to be looking for it in this game
um or or a draw at the very least
position is completely equal I actually
like her Pawn structure even though she
has double pawns she has absolute
control over the center
so
yeah definitely very soon and you know
what we're going to get a nice long game
yeah
let's uh which game has your interest
the most maybe we can pop just straight
back to that Dominguez game
see is anything majorly exciting
happened so we saw it was this line with
Bishop to G5 and now let's see what
happened after Bishop to D7 castles
Queen to E7 B4 played now G5 maybe some
indication that black is not going to be
castling on the king's side black waits
for white to Castle and then maybe maybe
I'll tell you where I'm castling maybe
I'm not going to be castling uh okay so
H5 H4 is played G4 played now comes
Knight to E1 D5 Knight to C2
any thoughts on this one oh opposites
I'm not too sure how I feel about this
opposite sight castling at the moment
black spawns are completely fixed
there's no way for
the pawns to be pushing uh for black
spawns to continue pushing up so in this
case I don't think you know opposite
side cosplay makes that much sense for
Wei but I could be wrong maybe he's
looking at
as long as white doesn't play something
like e takes D5 and lose control of the
F5 square there's no way for the black
pawn to really push up so it's just a
very Dynamic game and we use just one of
those players that absolutely enjoys
um attacking chess and I think it's
going to show in this game which forces
Dominguez to actually answer so we might
not get into all this game I'm kind of
excited I know that's all we need we
need we need no draws draws are no help
whatsoever in the magic right we just
need four wins but uh it doesn't I mean
at some point though this is you
mentioned hooks earlier I mean we have
this hook here that can be used
potentially in the very near future so
we'll keep our eyes on this one come on
Dominguez you gotta come through for us
so let's head back uh to the Ben Bach
game this one looked good I just quickly
saw the eval bar get out of control wild
so this we saw up to here we saw this
move and now this bishop has come out
uh we see we just grabbed that Bond
thank you very much Rook to B8 attack
The Rook wait I mean this is I mean this
this is going just well look at this
oh okay it's almost a free Queen but it
almost doesn't matter because after
Bishop C8 all of white uh sorry all
blacks pieces all of Joe entrance pieces
are going to be stuck on the back rank
defending that Bishop so after Queen to
F3 Queen to A8 that light squared Bishop
is going down so this will actually be
Benjamin box win I mean I'm saying it
now but uh we're calling it okay we're
counting the chickens yeah we're calling
it exactly it is nice that after you
play this move there's no real entry for
this queen so the Queen's not even
coming into E1 the Knight on kind of
this weird awkward squares defending the
back Rank and it's also keeping pressure
on this Pawn so it all it's all just
kind of working here I would expect that
we're able to hopefully win this one
relatively clean cleanly so let's come
back we'll check out what's going on
with Benjamin Bach but so far that could
be an amazing game for us okay uh this
is the Nicholas theodoro game we were
watching this from the black side he
this is the F5 game we saw uh up to here
with f 5 white has come up with Bishop
to D3 now came a bishop check King moved
over now the file gets opened up this
allows this Rook to come on in if it
wants to it decides to come in right
away Queen to H5 okay let's just pay
attention to our H Pawn but you know
what
who is going to land the punch
well I do think black's gonna land the
punch because I I think Nicholas can
just play H6 and there's not really a
real threat from White so after h626 it
is
yeah any Queen H7 you can just play King
of f8 your Rook on A8 is protected and
anytime they go Queen to AJ you can
always play Kings F7 so I think I think
black's position is totally fine here
it's just a matter of you know I don't
know if you want to play Rick a f8 here
I I'm not entirely sure but in the game
it looks like after H6 uh White played
B5 okay to the game here H6 played B5
all right
very interesting trying to Break Stuff
open on the queen side here let's just
ignore that that Knight's hanging hey
let's bring this Rook into the f8
potentially setting up some mating
threads here on the back rank the bishop
is protected by the queen so how does
white defend against the threat of Rook
to F1
yeah and after work do
I don't really know what's going to play
93 perhaps I mean The Bishop's hanging
but maybe that's right a non-essential
Bishop our Knight is also hanging
can you play Rook
four to A1 Erick a to A1 is that a move
instead of Knight to E3 instead of
Knight to E3 can we just simply bring
our Rook back in order to defend the
back rank
yeah certainly appears so I'm imagining
that we have some way to move our Knight
out but
yeah I mean I don't know why this
doesn't hold me and black is so close
I'm just like one I just need like one
more little piece or one more little way
to kind of break into this position for
black
but yeah maybe we will see this let's
see what happens in the game
uh in the game we did have a move and it
was Knight to E3 okay keeping control of
the F1 Square preventing the back rank
mate
and now I mean it feels like black is
right there if you can just find
a good move here
and the Knight is attacked I figure you
probably don't you're not taking back
this Pawn although maybe you can I think
it's all about the previous activity so
I'm imagining the Knight just coming
closer keeping it right maybe just
Knight T5 yeah keep an eye on some of
these important squares don't let the
queen come in
open up these Bishops on each other
we'll see what he comes up with this is
kind of a critical moment again we need
everybody to win but if Bach is doing
well if theodoro is doing well you know
Dominguez got an opposite side castling
Alice is keeping it solid she wants to
be the All-Star at the very end playing
a super solid game
you know
don't tell me it's not possible
certainly if definitely anything is
possible here
this is how we like to do it here in St
Louis you know we like it to come down
to the fourth quarter and then win with
a big Hail Mary
I if if we win all four games at once
that would be pretty insane that must be
a first I don't think any team has just
completely sweeping around look we don't
want to just win the championship we
want to break all the records okay
everybody's still warming up here so you
know a lot of opportunities uh Queen
yeah Queen okay a G6 so because you
didn't put your knight here and stop me
I'm coming into G6 you need to be a
little bit cautious about this check now
wait is there no free rook uh maybe The
Rook might be yeah I think that's just
because I mean you're worried about some
check here I don't know if it's right
because I mean if you play Bishop to G6
probably afraid of King to E7 and then
there's also there's Knight to D5
but maybe we just run away maybe we can
just take that
Queen to G7 I'm not too scared about I
was more scared of Knight D5 after King
E7 because it's a freaking five wait yes
but but wait but the back wait wait wait
but you don't have background Checkmate
because we're gonna have to take it this
way yeah and we're threatening a back
ranky but wait this is scary
or it's at least complicated you got to
figure all this out but we would be
threatening this here
uh yeah white actually doesn't really
have a defense so you can play if if y
plays Bishop D3 so first of all you
can't play anything like G4 G4 doesn't
really matter because you have like
Knight to D4 like Checkmate and stuff
yeah so we want to just take this
is there anything else you're worried
about here
well
I did not mention Knight G4 but I don't
think Knight G4 is a very realistic move
to play I Feel Like much more logical as
Bishop G6 95. but I guess I shouldn't
say that I mean she is is a grand master
he's 2500. I'm sure he's not playing
objective Knight to E5 is what was
played okay protecting this G6 square at
last so now when the king comes to F7
you're not worried about any checks on
G6 and everything is kind of stabilized
also you know a lot of danger could
happen here if this is capturing now
comes Knight to G4
we see the quick capture so I'm
imagining White's idea was to do
something now in the G6 Square before
recapturing this Knight
but we'll see what happens here
looking for I mean wait wait's looking
for something
yeah I'm not entirely sure what
white is looking for because I think
this is just very very winning at some
moment when this bishop is gone you're
also looking at these kinds of
checkmating threats by black all of
these things would be well protected
yeah for sure and if you play something
like B takes before once again The Rook
is still hanging and uh without the
Knight on without a knight going to D5
it's even clearer than before
Wow Let's Go Nicholas theodoro
getting it done
absolutely I'm really I'm really happy
about that let's go back many wins we're
coming back but let's go see how
Benjamin Bach is doing okay Benjamin is
also winning yeah we saw up to here we
saw this queen F3 was played
uh there's your all of your moves all of
your analysis it came true so he's able
to win pieces okay there's still a
little issue of this D4 Pawn you
know we'll see he's able to just push
this Pawn the queen is just further
white is on such a perfect diagonal
the pieces are so well harmonized here
for white I'll make the queen just to
win win a night at least
beautiful beautiful
oh no it looks like his name did end I
was like this should end any minute it
looks like it's okay yeah
okay there's a way we only
unfortunately Dominguez has lost against
way he no wow how did wait what happened
there did you see the rock on H1 no I
didn't see anything what happened okay
so we got to this position
somehow ah somehow black is the queen
just came in and took a pawn
yeah you were like look how solid this
is
wow B5 moving the pieces on your king
side not so easy to do but if you come
in and you take a pawn
oh no yeah just a free pot oh that's all
the work ended up on each one what what
holy cow that's pretty crazy so if you
take your taking back with the queen
and then yes it's not so easy because if
you try to keep your Bishop alive
I think just G3 or what
yeah G3 Bishop takes G3 Queen takes G3
because it's pinned oh
it's so much pain
ah so because of that in the game uh I
had to put the sad Bishop back oh no
yeah what a monster Bishop this super
secret sniper bishop and after Knight D4
that's just where the game ended oh no
and so I'm feeling this is
yeah I feel like this is one of those
positions where you ask people how do
you how did The Rook end up on H1 yeah
like what the heck
how did The Rook even end up on H1
the interesting uh final position but
very unfortunate result for Dominguez
who has I mean game of the day but not
for our team so I mean yeah enough for
our team playing this insane game uh
Benjamin Bach did officially win his
game okay we saw the last move in that
one we will not be uh forcing a playoff
here Nicholas theodoro was also able to
win
um we saw at this point let's flip the
board we were seeing this from black
this one officially finished
after taking uh we saw this check Bishop
comes all the way back Knight takes and
now that position is starting to
stabilize and here is where the game
ended the queen is attacked and I
suppose there's no way you don't have
time to recapture because there's stuff
going on on the back rank uh this check
doesn't really do anything because we're
just recapturing uh and so you just
resigned so congrats to Nicholas
theodoro doing what he needed to do uh
also some sad news on the last board so
I think in the end there were all
decisive results which is exactly what
we were looking for we saw this game out
unfortunately we needed a couple more in
our favor but uh yeah well it wasn't a
miracle but it was an interesting way
she was going for it look she was coming
in she was going for mate
you can't she can't make a draw she's
got to keep playing on
could have some moments in this game
maybe she was like okay though I have to
keep playing on and then thankfully she
did but it didn't quite go her way Queen
snuck all the way in and oh not any way
to defend against that so okay not like
the greatest start we showed a lot of
effort there in the the final quarter
but uh it wasn't quite meant to be so
the Shanghai uh Knights the Shanghai
Tigers will Tigers winning this match
this is their their first if they're
able to get to three then congrats to
them they're gonna guarantee a playoff
so we need to bounce back in the next
week
um from here Nemo what are your kind of
thoughts overall on the day
honestly I think I I think losing you
know
six to ten is a little unfortunate I
feel like a lot of the games we could
have had a much better grasp on
um I I do think that
with the board one draws it's a little
bit tough for the rest of the team to
follow up and provide good results
because a lot of the players are going
to be playing against people much higher
rated than them but other than that I
feel like Dominguez had a very very
solid showing and you know he's just
getting started it's just day one we
still have former matches potentially to
go as long as we don't lose the next two
in a row which I don't think will happen
but all of these teams have been really
strong the Shanghai Tigers field and Wei
some super strong players
they're female players you know Jew and
literally the Women's World Champion
yeah very just some really they got a
lot of people going forward
and hopefully we can show some of our
potential going forward in our next
round it will be sometime between
Tuesday and Friday the matches they
haven't been fully decided yet but we'll
definitely be back or at least Captain
Nemo will definitely be back maybe it'll
be me maybe it'll be different people
you never know what you're going to
expect but hopefully next time we're
able to get a bigger win Nemo it was a
real pleasure being able to spend this
time analyzing with the games with you
uh I had a blast and you know what it
didn't go our way this time but uh we'll
be back and hopefully it goes a little
bit better in the future yes
thank you so much Jonathan you've been
an absolute pleasure to co-host with
it's been a lot of fun the games have
been insanely interesting yeah I think
every single player played really well I
think Alice Lee had some great chances
Benjamin and Nicholas both showed up
they performed
some really strong players here you know
um getting these upsets getting these
wins so we got good games all around and
next week I'm sure it'll be even better
absolutely so hopefully everybody stays
tuned hopefully everybody's following
both the channels we are live on the sdl
chess club uh twitch and YouTube
channels we are also live on the AKA AKA
nemsco twitch channel so hopefully
thanks to everybody that's been watching
and until next time we'll see you in St
Louis
thank you guys
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited